vamos a jugar con los diferentes tipos
de rectas que podemos trazar en un plano
cartesiano te propongo que si tienes uno
a la mano vayas trazando conmigo las
rectas para ver qué figura se forma sino
con mucha atención para que lo hagas
después tenemos el siguiente plano
cartesiano recuerda que el eje
horizontal es x y el vertical es la
primera recta que trazaremos será igual
a 4 y queda de la siguiente manera
en esta recta no importa el valor de x
porque ella siempre vale 4 entonces
quiere decir que es una recta constante
ahora trazaremos una recta con ye igual
a 2 x menos cuatro para trazar la basta
con ubicar dos puntos y unirlos
así que si sustituimos la x por un 2
queda allí igualados por 2 menos 4 y eso
es igual a 0 por lo tanto nuestro primer
punto está en 2 0
para el otro punto sustituimos x con
menos 2 y obtenemos ya igualados por
menos 2 menos 4 es igual a menos 8
nuestro segundo punto será menos 2 coma
menos 8
un tip en el plano cartesiano marca el
punto donde justo debe pasar la recta e
inclusive puedes dibujar una línea
punteada hacia él
recuerda que el primer número que
tenemos va en equis y el segundo en ye
así que esta recta debe quedar mucho más
inclinada
excelente trazamos otra recta muy
similar a la anterior lo único que
cambiaremos será el signo de x esto
quiere decir que será una recta con
inclinación contraria a la otra y a su
vez será recíproca si la anterior fue
igual a 2 x menos 4 ésta será 10 igual a
menos 2 x menos 4
para el primero sustituimos x con menos
2 y obtenemos de igual a menos dos por
menos dos menos cuatro igual a cero
para el segundo sustituimos x con 2 y
queda ye igual a menos dos por dos menos
cuatro igual a menos ocho así que
nuestras coordenadas son 20 y dos como
menos ocho ponemos los puntos para
trazar la línea
ahora hagamos otra mucho más inclinada
con ye igual a 6 x + 11 como crees que
quede realicemos la ecuación para
conocer las dos coordenadas que
necesitamos para trazar la recta para el
primer punto en x lo haremos con 0 así
que queda ye igual a 6 por 0 más 11 y el
resultado es 11
para el segundo punto vamos a sustituir
x con menos 2 quedando de la siguiente
manera
e igual a 6 x menos dos más 11 igual a
menos 1 vamos muy bien las coordenadas
son 0,11 y menos 2 coma menos uno atrás
hemos nuestra recta wow
creo que ya puedes adivinar qué figura
estamos formando sólo nos hace falta una
recta más para completarlo
esta será muy similar a la anterior es
decir recíproca la ecuación que ahora
trataremos es ye igual a menos 6 x + 11
para obtener el primer punto sustituimos
x con 0 entonces tenemos que igual a
menos 6 por 0 + once y obtenemos 11
nuestra primer coordenada es
0,11 para el segundo a equis le daremos
un valor de 2 y queda como ye igual a
menos 6 por 2 más 11 igual a menos 1
entonces nuestra segunda coordenada es 2
menos uno perfecto al trazar nuestra
última recta obtenemos una estrella que
padre borremos las líneas punteadas y
las marcas de las coordenadas para
apreciar mejor la estrella quedó muy
bien como te diste cuenta
fuimos transformando la ecuación para
trazar varias rectas
si queremos trazar rectas
perpendiculares es importante que en la
ecuación modifiquemos el signo de x por
menos o más según sea el caso para una
recta más horizontal dividimos x en la
ecuación y para hacer la paralela le
aumentamos o disminuimos valores a x es
decir colocamos alguno más 3 o menos 2 a
nuestra ecuación así que sigue te
divirtiendo al formar ecuaciones para
generar rectas